hello and welcome back to another
episode of big moves
uh we have tiff me and yesterday and you
guys might notice that nikki's not here
she's not here with us today but she'll
be back next time don't worry
she's gone come back i can kick her out
she's good she's fine don't worry
it's cool she can't leave us yeah she'll
be back there's no drama we're good
um today's episode is uh possible
because of you guys
we posted on instagram for you guys to
message us
about your relationship problems that
you have had or have right now
and we're going to address them and
see it's like a round table of aunties
yeah we're going to decide if you should
break up or not some of them may they
may have already broken up but we just
want to talk about it anyway right
we love the drama right of your shitty
relationships
because we've been there we've all been
there very very badly yeah
also i think it's important to mention
the type of people we are
in relationships right right because i
feel like just by knowing you guys
and by knowing myself we like you two
seem to be a little similar in terms of
like
[ __ ] it peace out i'm gone like you will
not
like ride the wave yep and i am the
complete opposite i will
i will stay there and be like no
[ __ ] this is gonna work because
it's gonna work you will fight tooth and
nail to make that man change
if even if it takes seven or eight years
yep you will invest all of that time
whereas gina and i are like no we're
good
i'm fine i'm out i'm good yep yep so
there you go so just
come going into this you can at least
know the type of people that
that are here right we're going to be
discussing and no answer is probably
correct and none of our answers are
probably like
exact advice you should take we don't
know your lives like we're
definitely not perfect people we're not
therapists we don't know
[ __ ] we're just talking about our
opinions
on your shitty relationship gina do you
want to do you wanna
you wanna get us into a shitty
relationship get us into the first
post and we're gonna make all of these
anonymous just because we don't know
who's okay with
having their name shouted out or not
even if they didn't specifically say to
make it anonymous it's probably
we're just going to keep that we don't
want to get you in trouble yeah yeah
all right we're starting off with the
first one that we got here is
i don't even know where to start oh god
that's how they start
yeah that's a strong start uh she says
we've been together for six years and
have a family a home
and everything together but i feel like
i'm doing all the work on top of my nine
to five
this house wouldn't run without me no
one would eat without me and on top of
it i just feel like i'm always asking
for some attention
or he'll be in a mood and say that he
just doesn't want to be around anyone
and goes to hang out with his boys
and when we argue it's almost always
about the same things over and over
again i've honestly tried to leave
before and he tells me things will
change
and they haven't i used to be a sucker
and always get a
heart face when he would walk or when he
would talk about us getting married
and now when he brings it up i don't
even react
yeah sounds like she fell out of love
ooh girl what are you doing in that
relationship still
i know i remember yesterday is bad yeah
it's a long time they're not even
married yet but they have a family and
everything so they're
she kind of like put the cart before the
horse it sounds like and now he doesn't
have to try anymore
she's doing a lot of wife things for
someone who's not for a boyfriend
i remember um i was in a relationship
once it was like a long term one and
it was good it was good it was good like
we talked about marriage and then like
things were starting to kind of fall
apart and then i knew it was over
when uh he brought up one day it was
very simple he's like
oh i can't actually want to buy this
thing i'm like oh yeah i should go ahead
and buy it and then he goes
actually now i should be saving for your
ring and instead of getting excited i
was like
you could feel it in your gut where are
you yeah i don't want to marry you
yeah don't say ring bye that's when i
broke it off i was like if i feel like
that
maybe this is not a good sign yeah well
her body seems to be telling her maybe
in her mind too
but she's not actually putting anything
into motion and i know right now
especially in a pandemic it's really
hard she has a family with this person
and they're probably financially tied up
and this is like the worst time to like
start out on your own i get it
um but you know we've only got until
summer you know the vaccine's going to
come out so girls start
pocketing some money put it away
make your escape yeah i mean the fact
that she's
she's getting absolutely no like she
doesn't have a partner she has another
child there
and i know how that feels sometimes but
not fully to that extent because casey
was not
that bad like he did help like he helps
a lot and
he does a lot of cooking he is a partner
for sure but i'm saying like if i was in
this girl's shoes specifically in her
shoes i think i would already be
leaving because there's no way like
there's no there's no
partnership there is just like a huge
bag of
[ __ ] that you're the one you're the
only one carrying this
and if your partner's not willing to
carry his own weight or at least
acknowledge the fact that he's just dead
weight like straight up dead weight like
what is he doing
what is he doing like the minimum she
wanted was just time and attention
he didn't give her that he has a a
living maid yeah
or a second mom not a girlfriend girl
that's what you are you're a living maid
for free men that are shitty not all men
shitty men will stay with a girl for a
long time even if they have no intention
of really treating her well or anything
because there is a benefit to having a
woman around and that is
[ __ ] cleaning your dirty socks making
sure you have food at the table every
day like doing everything for you so
don't think that he
loves you just because he's keeping you
around i think he loves the free
labor right yeah
cold hard facts there and also like to
me it really speaks volumes how
there's um there's nothing
beneficial that she sees in him like
there's nothing good
that she's at least throwing in there to
give some context in the relationship
it's just like purely like
listen i'm in this situation what the
[ __ ] do i do and you know the answer
girl
you know exactly just by the way that
she wrote it she knows the answer
already it's just really hard to face
the truth
it's hard to um start i mean after six
years too
because like i was in a five year that i
waited i wasted time we both wasted time
in that relationship because it wasn't
going to go anywhere and it is hard
because your identity is just built
around this other person
and you don't even remember what it's
like to be single and like
to even think about just being alone
just like having your bed empty again
and just all these things it can be very
very scary
but you kind of get over that after a
couple months and then you go back to
being like empowered and feel good and
like you don't have to
do so many chores for someone that's not
really adding to your life
so it's like it's a very scary thing to
like leave but it's actually so much
better once you get through
to the other side and you can actually
find someone that will love you
and not just use you as a maid right i'm
also a big like
so you guys know how i am in
relationships i want my attention
so when i don't get my attention oh gina
is baby
baby so if i don't get that attention i
like
lose my [ __ ] right yeah temper tantrums
yeah
yeah i mean like i don't scream with
throat tantrums but inside like yeah
emotional temperatures you have to see
me in
these messages yeah so
like for her to be pretty much begging
him for attention which is the bare
minimum in her relationship and he still
doesn't
it's because he doesn't respect her no
and then rather go out with his friends
i'm a firm believer in uh if they really
wanted to they would
yeah yeah if you really wanted to he
would you know
so i always think that like an ounce of
effort
exactly at least minimum bare minimum
because yeah sure no one's perfect and
even if you want to you're not going to
nail it the first time but at least
there's effort
and progress if you really want to be
better
you know what also stands out to me too
is the fact that they have a family
and i know how hard that can be
like being in a relationship that
you know is already entangled with
a child like you know because my
previous relationship for example it
wasn't with isaac's dad
and i had isaac and so you know it was a
very toxic relationship and
it also didn't help the fact that he
would throw that in my face too like
who's gonna take you with another kid
like with a kid or whatever
so it was it was crazy right so then
that would help me stay in that
relationship like
it was like brainwashing kind of it's
like you're not lovable
so exactly so i can only feel for this
girl because the fact that they have a
family
she probably feels like well [ __ ] like
he's the father of my kids like
like i can't replace that role or
whatever
and she probably feels like she needs to
stay
for the kids but the thing is that i
realized
in my previous relationship was that if
i end up being
in a toxic relationship what am i
teaching my son like what is he learning
from me and being in that relationship
me being unhappy like what is
what kind of lessons what kind of man is
he going to grow up to be and how is he
going to treat his
his woman like if i'm letting myself get
treated the way i do so
that helped me leave that relationship
because yeah that is scary like what
because it's like what's the lesser of
the two evils right like being a single
mom or having like the two-parent
household thing which i guess can be
stressful it depends on how old they are
maybe if they're like in
middle school it's probably a lot easier
to deal with i don't i don't know i mean
you have more yeah my kid's in middle
school i mean do you think he's dealing
with that easier now than he was
the two-parent thing in elementary
school or did he is it maybe worse now i
don't know
honestly i don't know if i would label
it as better or worse
it's just a constant it's a constant
thing that everyone involved in is
getting
like is adapting to because as this
child grows up
he he ends up being a completely
different person year after year so then
we all have to adapt to
how his brain has developed how he's
he's uh
um absorbing the whole situation so
selfish
but like yeah i really can't tell you if
it was easier or harder
because it's just different problems
like different
different ways of coping and luckily
like isaac
does have a parent team of three that we
all
really get along and we're all just
focused on making sure like
what can we do that is the best for
isaac but there's a lot of
other um what do they call it mix family
there
there's a term oh um yeah now that now
that you're asking for the term i forgot
it but
that term right family something like
that i can't remember right now but
households
i don't know but the point is like when
there's there's children involved and
like the parents are together and
there's other people involved all that
right
so in in a lot of other households that
are like that
the parents end up being very selfish
like they end up thinking like
well i hate my ex so i'm gonna make sure
to get at my ex and i don't give a [ __ ]
if it's gonna affect my kid or not like
unfortunately there's a lot of shitty
parents like that
and so they end up using the kids as
weapons pretty much
and then that ends up being like harming
the kid even more right
so then like having like making sure to
put your own ego aside
for the betterment of your kid that's
honestly like what
is the winning formula yeah so like not
maybe
having um i guess what you would call a
traditional household with the mom and
the dad
in the same house even though they hate
each other like there's good and bad in
that like if you can figure out how to
pretend to have a family that's like
loving and caring and
you can show a great example like the
dad kind of pretends to still
love the mom in front of the kid until
he's old enough to get out of the house
like i guess that could help them see
something healthy but then if it's not
that if they're not like doing a good
job at kind of faking it until they make
it
then the kid is just seeing like
negative
like this is what a relationship is it's
like my mom is sad all the time and
alone and just in the kitchen and then
my dad is just always with his friends
or like exactly
smoking weed or whatever like just not
like if the if they're not
like in it then that's really damaging
to the kid but then also if they're
apart and they're being super
like drama toxic all of that like so i
guess
i mean if you choose to leave that
relationship it'll probably make you
both happier as individuals
and then as long as you both agree to
not treat the kid as some pawn in the
middle then that's probably the best
situation overall right mature enough to
do that
you know that's really scary but i mean
i i can't say this for everyone but
hopefully with time
maturity does come because that was my
situation i mean maybe he's like
years of like can you please put your
ego aside
for our kid like this is not about us
anymore
yeah and eventually we got there so do
you think that maybe he's just staying
too because he feels
like out of obligation like he's like
well i don't want my kid to like not
have their dad around so i'm here but
you're not getting any part of me you
know like you're i'm not gonna give you
[ __ ] but i'll just be here in the house
with the kids
but yeah imagine we get a message from
the other side yeah
i know i would love to hear both sides
of the story but it just sounds
like if one person really wants the
relationship to be like
involved and the other person's just
kind of icing them out then
they're really not contributing at all
and
so i don't i think that you deserve
better as a human being i think it's
better to
kind of have a little period of time
where you're alone
in order to get something that you
deserve versus to never be alone but
just always have something shitty
right you know i don't i don't like
people who aren't receptive
to uh suggestions and problem solving
yeah you know it's the ego that's what
it is it's ego and also
lack of consideration and care for the
other person
well it sounds like they she brings it
up all the time they fight about the
same things he's like okay i'll change
so like he's he's admitting that he's
not doing enough but i think he really
just
doesn't love you enough because if he
did he would change
right i think a lot of people confuse
when it comes to asking someone to
fix a problem with them they confuse
real change
with compliance so what he's doing with
you is just
a compliance to maybe just make you
happy for a little bit right now
but when [ __ ] hits the fan again did he
really change it didn't really come from
within him
like it wasn't hit like he has no desire
to do what he needs to do to make you
happy
because i don't think he loves you
enough right a lot of people just
complain
or even herself happiness himself he
doesn't want happiness for his own
family
yeah because i think a man that sees his
family is kind of
wobbling it's not doing well the
relationships like he he would at some
point
find it within himself to stand up and
like make things better like hey we're
gonna go to therapy we're gonna figure
this out we're gonna
get our roll up our sleeves and like try
to make it better
he's not doing any of that he ain't
worth the [ __ ]
packing bags girl we're going back to
the streets
we got a few months towards till summer
we can do this come on
that's so funny well so yeah milf out
there come on
oh there's a lot of guys that are
willing to date single moms too by the
way
you are not damaged material a lot of
guys too they're like i don't even
really want kids of my own but like you
have some and they already come in these
cute little packages at six years old so
i don't have to change diapers they're
like perfect
sign me up you know so yeah you're not
undesirable
don't worry don't think you're broken
goods cause i know exactly what that
feels like
look at tiff she's a milf yeah plenty of
dudes totalness
have no idea you should see your dms all
right
so uh next message is uh my birthday was
in september and i remember me myself
always being considerate and kind i told
my boyfriend that it's okay we don't
have to spend money or do anything crazy
expensive for my birthday per usual
oh boy okay um i know i can see
this is already problematic yeah stop
just stop saying that
first of all just stop saying that dude
let's give her the benefit of doubt
let's see okay but
in three exclamation points god damn it
come on girl i tried i can't i
but it was actually our first time
together for my birthday
and so we went out to eat sushi but i
paid for it no biggie
although wait oh for your birthday
she paid for her own birthday sushi
okay well the fact that she's saying no
biggie it's like
well okay it's not a problem but oh
she's building resistance
she's building resentment as the as the
sentence continues go ahead gina
but she's also doing this on her own
like she's she's she's handing this
resentment to herself
she is she is um
although although i remember him telling
me he doesn't have a lot of money due to
quote bills
hence the fact that we do live together
i was pretty bummed out that i didn't
get spoiled to
lavished wait
girlfriend you said it was no big deal
why
are you [ __ ] out okay stop lying to
yourself yeah you're straight-up blind
stop lying to yourself
and stop setting him up by saying oh
it's no big deal
and then expecting it like why she's
she's a cool girl that's why i know what
that feels this is okay
this is something we have to work on but
go ahead gina continue
uh i was bummed out that i wasn't
spoiled with lavish things but i also
remember that i should
appreciate anything and whatever i get
because it's all my accounts
okay yes that makes me angry too okay go
ahead
furthermore three days after i get after
my birthday
remember we live together i opened the
mailbox to get my check and i saw his
bank statement mail
i usually don't open it because i don't
care
but something was whispering in my ears
to open it so i did it
i know that feeling so well that
intuition and
gut feeling and it's always
always right what'd she find you know so
i did and i guess he was broke because
he had been using his credit cards to
pay for someone's
only fan
how many is it just one account
geez is it just one somewhere it's
getting worse like you know
it's like this is a style plural
someone's
someone i really want i feel like we
need to start like the next episode we
do of these we need to ask for their
like
age and their location because i need to
know like
where did you grow up and how old are
you because how are you this stupid
anyways let's go oh
my god jack because this is stupid no
this is stupid this whole relationship
is done no
she's definitely young she's definitely
a young or she could just be a pushover
i don't know like there's people like
that out there
okay do you wear fedoras and think they
actually look good
if you do honey you need some styling
help and
stitch fix is here to help you
as the days get longer and the weather
gets colder
it may be time to take a look at your
winter wardrobe if you want to make a
change this season
stitch fix can help you choose some new
pieces that you'll love if you want to
finally get laid
fedoras yeah the fedoras are not helping
you
um just everyone with the fedora
i'm helping you yeah stitch fix is
helping you so when you take your stitch
fix quiz
and you see a fedora pop up on the quiz
go ahead and click down
and just don't do the fedoras but other
than that you can go ahead and click uh
yes i like this shirt yes i like these
pants
no i don't like that type of sweater and
then they'll go ahead and curate a
collection of clothes that you can try
out
in the comfort of your own home yeah
real stylists curate your
wardrobe yes there's a person and you
can give them notes and the last time i
got a stitch fix i was like hey
i don't want any more jeans i know that
i love your jeans but i have
57 pairs of jeans in my closet i need
more dresses
i'm like i've been too tomboyish for too
long and i want some more dresses so
they sent me only dresses so they
actually listen to what you ask for
it's very customizable super easy and
also you don't have to
um you don't have to stick with the
subscription you can just order like
whenever you want so if you just want it
this week but
not next month or whatever they'll
customize it to whatever you want
try on the pieces at home before you buy
keep what you love and return what you
don't
stitch fix has free shipping easy
returns and exchanges and a prepaid
return envelope
is included it's super easy there's no
subscription required
try stitch fix once or set up automatic
deliveries you'll pay just a 20
styling fee for each box which will get
credited towards the pieces you keep
and there are no hidden fees ever stitch
fix has styles
and clothing to fit any occasion for
women men and kids and they ship
all over the us and it's also available
in the uk
get started today at stitchfix.com mood
and you'll get 25 off when you keep
everything in your fix
that is stitchfix.com mood
for 25 off when you keep everything in
your fix
stitchfix.com
[Laughter]
yeah and while you're looking great you
can also eat good
eat some nice and fresh and delicious
meals
by hellofresh with hellofresh getting
nutritious home-cooked meals on the
table has never been easier
especially with low calorie vegetarian
and family-friendly recipes
with hellofresh you get fresh
pre-measured ingredients and
mouth-watering seasonal recipes
delivered right to your door
hellofresh is 46 cheaper than shopping
at your local grocery store
and you get nutritious home-cooked meals
on the table in about 30 minutes or less
i'm normally super intimidated by
cooking but hello fresh makes it easy
fun and affordable just to tell you a
recipe i made recently that was
so delicious was this spicy maple
chicken
with smashed sweet potatoes and roasted
green beans oh my goodness just thinking
about it makes my mouth watery all over
again it was
so good so to get america's number one
meal kit
go to hellofresh.com 10 big mood
and use code 10 big mood for 10 free
meals
including free shipping that's
hellofresh.com
10 big mood and use code 10 big mood for
10 free meals including free shipping
yay
yeah treat yourself don't burn the water
okay so he's paying for only fans and
she bought her own birthday sushi okay
continue
that really hurt me and he told me it
was my fault for going through his
privacy
no the gas lighting
oh jeez i'm so mad i don't know who to
fight him
or smacking her for being dumb like okay
i love
i my sister you are my sister yes now
it's a sister
i want to beat the [ __ ] out of you
they're like what the hell
like what are you doing oh my god oh no
imagine being 22 again paying for your
own birthday sushi and then find out
your boyfriend's
paying like cam girls or only fans girl
like he's basically paying
that's like personal porn yeah that's
not just like oh i log into pornhub
like on saturday you know it's like i'm
paying this girl who i have an
attachment to to see her naked and to
jack off to her
yeah you are gonna buy you oh my
birthday sushi
like i don't like when it's that
personal when is that direct that
personal that direct
me and my book i would classify that as
i agree i agree it's two
it's two like you have too much of a
direct
line to this specific girl and you're
paying her bill she probably has
thousands of guys giving her money
and your own girlfriend had to buy her
own sushi
yeah for her birthday and then he had
the audacity to get upset
at her for her how dare you find out
what you're doing
oh i think snooping at this point in my
life i'm like if you feel that [ __ ] and
you find it you were meant to be yeah
you were meant to find it yeah
so the the other thing too oh is there
more or is that it
let's yeah let's finish let's finish it
off real quick let me get more angry
oh my god he said it was my
fault for going through his privacy and
i don't know if it was right for him to
get so angry at me
oh mom i was just mad at myself help it
still lingers in my heart because he
lied that he was broke from bills but he
was paying for someone else's holy
spirit
july all the way past my birthday it's
multiple months
of only fans so july august september oh
wait
three three four months yeah only fans
and that means so they live
together yeah so she knows how much he
makes and what the bills are she knows
she should know like how much he can
afford well no i mean maybe he
contributes a bare minimum without
telling you exactly how much she makes
but the shitty thing why would you live
with somebody if you have no [ __ ]
clue how much they make i've been there
really yeah oh you don't ask enough
questions girl yeah
no it was also difficult to know exactly
he was an artist
so like he would be commissioned like
big amounts
sometimes and then nothing other times
that makes more sense
i would be the one paying most of the
bills so he's been
paying for this only fan since july
knowing that his girlfriend's coming up
his birthday his girlfriend's birthday
is coming up in september he couldn't
stock away
a few dollars for dinner no the part
that really
canceled for that month is how she was
like i was mad at myself
yeah why you were so in the right
to follow your intuition sure okay there
is like
an ethical line that was crossed by
going into his private [ __ ]
i i think that that is that is an
ethical line that has been crossed but
it is justified in my opinion
because of the fact that yeah like dude
you're living with the dude
he [ __ ] nuts in your [ __ ] you can go
through his mail
like if they were married then yeah i
wouldn't think that ethical life if they
were married then he has no privacy
yeah no privacy but yeah but i know
i know that to me is my life he's
playing house
so he should know his [ __ ] bills are
coming into that house his
fake wife because i just want to see
what she looks like oh no
i'm not going to say it but i'm i am i
am like upset i'm
enraged as what i am gina i am enraged
she can't even speak
oh it's on private oh no she's a nurse
she's a nurse so she's old enough yeah
damn dude she's cute from her profile
picture she's cute
she's cute and she has a good job and
she's dating a guy she really [ __ ]
made her pay for her own birthday dinner
she looks really young though
okay that is something to consider
because are you a brand new nurse
yeah i could think like like early
mid-20s
tiff would probably be in st like
similar shoes
like even i would feel yeah i guess i've
been there i've been yeah
i've never paid for my own [ __ ]
birthday dinner but i've been there
even when i was broke when i was younger
whenever we went out for birthdays
things like we all chipped in as much as
we could
yeah he didn't ship it at all she paid
the whole birthday bill like come on
dude like
oh that's like some small dick energy
[ __ ] i'm turned off yeah
i'm turned off heavily right now that's
who is this guy like you message me i
just want
the audacity that's all he has why are
men
the audacity that's all he has she just
has the audacity of it oh my god
it's just it's it's um it angers me
because it reminds me of like
situations when i've dealt with men that
were just very clearly still
teenage boys and then when you confront
them with their wrongdoings they have
the audacity to get angry at you for
[ __ ] finding out like how dare you
find out i [ __ ] up right like
right [ __ ] you yeah owen up to your [ __ ]
be a [ __ ] man because it's some
little boy [ __ ] i think get upset
is some little boy [ __ ] right the the
what is it the means justify the ends
when it comes to like
if i have to maybe ask your best friend
or if i have to
look at your mail or if i look at your
like the means to me
justify the ends to know that you're
[ __ ] cheating on me or you're you
know like you're doing something
wrong like i don't care how i had to
figure it out yeah the point is like
you're doing something wrong and you put
me in this [ __ ] position
of like having to live with this ugly
feeling in my gut like if you wanted to
do something wrong you should just be
like hey i'm like i can't really be in
this relationship i can't be there for
you the way you want me to i can't
[ __ ] take you out on dinners
i can't like what is this relationship
and this guy
is clearly nowhere near that also though
for her you need to fix a few things too
you want to get spoiled for your
birthday you want honest about it
don't be that that girl is just like oh
no no no it's fine you need to learn
this is communication issue you need to
be true to yourself
you know what you want and don't be
ashamed of that
yeah because like i said verbalize it
like you're handing yourself that
resentment exactly you you really put
yourself in that position and i know
exactly what that feels like because i
was into deep tiff
like i would get into situations that i
did not want to be in
and it was only because i didn't want to
upset anyone and i would just i didn't i
wanted to be cool girl
right i'm i'm really cool like that
benefits no one that benefits
it doesn't benefit him because now he
has to deal with you being upset later
regardless of if he's a piece of [ __ ] or
not which i
kind of feel like maybe he is but now he
has to deal with you being upset
now you have to deal with you being
upset like that's also like a level
of immaturity on her end it is a big
level of maturity because you think that
you're doing something it's also a level
of avoidance
like a huge avoidancy issue here and
avoidance
does not get you anything it doesn't
help any any of the parties involved it
ends up hurting you longer
and you end up staying stuck in a
situation that you're gonna end up
feeling resentment towards yourself
because you know what you're doing to
yourself
exactly and then you're gonna end up
like feeling shitty about yourself and
that's the opposite of what you're
trying to do girl you gotta
figure out that self-love like you can't
be upset
after telling someone to do exactly what
you know you told them to do this and
they did exactly what you told them and
now you're upset so that's
that's that's i don't want anything yeah
like girls we have to
stop stop that saying that dude
if you literally like i'm not a gift
person i even tell my friends i'm like
stop buying me gifts because i feel
bad because i can't i'm not a gift
person i don't want to
involve myself in gift giving for
birthdays or anything like i suck at
that i literally
don't want like but i do want us to hang
out i do want to have fun i do want us
to like go somewhere
like maybe get a little drunk or
something i would be like yes i want us
to like
acknowledge my birthday i don't want
gifts i'll say that but like for you for
this girl to be like oh i just oh it's
okay whatever and
i'll just buy myself a sushi dinner it's
like let's
stop we have to stop that little sister
oh my god
what would you do do you know yeah this
one i'm very
upset with yeah because this guy is just
shitty
it's just it's like nothing attractive
at all no consideration for a birthday
broke well i mean broke for the wrong
reasons right you know
because he's paying some girl on the
shoulder they're not even that expensive
i mean 100 bucks yeah ev if that i'm
sure they're not going to some like
super nice place just like a local sushi
spot you know i mean even if they are
either way
i mean 100 buck 200 bucks for a grown
woman sushi dinner sure
come on she's a nurse she's taking care
of dead people
and sick people and people [ __ ] on
themselves i was like
nurses take care of dead people no i
meant i didn't mean almost dead people
yeah
dying
that's what he does for a [ __ ] living
and that's why and i know that this is
highly
controversial but there's a saying you
could love a man
who is rich or you love a man who's poor
and i don't mean you have to only date
rich men but like don't fall in love
with a guy that's like
seriously a scrub because you're just
like this is the [ __ ] that you're going
to deal with he'll
not buy you birthday dinners and he'll
scrounge together his
pennies to pay for porn because he's a
scrub
geez pack your bags
going back to the streets
we need like a graphic for that back it
up
pack it up honey what would you say if
she if you would tell her to stay
[ __ ] because i feel like these are all
gonna be packed
so let's see what do we think about
number three do we have number three
yeah we have number three
i can't even get over number two right
now i'm very serious
and yes girl i think we had a lot of
submissions about their boyfriends
buying only fans and is that a problem
and to me
it is yeah to me like porn there's a
sliding scale
and i understand that a guy might look
up like if he looks at it a lot and he's
like got a
serious problem even if it is just
random like pornhub like not
only fans or whatever i think that's
still an issue um but if he's just like
a little dab he dips his toe in it once
in a while a few times
you know not not a constant basis then
maybe let it slide but only fans like
cam girls like all the [ __ ] that's they
have a direct line to i do feel like
that's
not good for your relationship and i
would be very upset by that i would
demand that it ends
immediately although i would probably
just not even want to be with that guy i
would be so pissed
and disgusted honestly it's disgusting
yeah because i mean everyone has their
line you just have to figure out where's
your line what are you comfortable in
with because i agree with jess like that
[ __ ] is crossing the line for
the only fans it should be for like
single guys
but then they'll be like they'll be
girls out there because um
because i was looking at some some like
uh commitment
stuff and looking into like how like
other people have different like
attachment styles or like commitment
standards yeah standards and and some
other like there are people out there
that they're perfectly fine they
actually feel
nothing negative when their partner is
like for example flirting with the girl
like in fact
a lot of people actually find that as a
turn-on so if to you
do they really or is that internalized
[ __ ] i don't know
i don't believe that i don't know i
think that's like a trauma response
to a guy cheating and now she's like oh
i love it probably
there's probably deeper issues there but
like i'm just looking at the surface
here
the surface is they say that if if you
truly like be honest with yourself right
if you truly truly
feel like oh my boyfriend can pay for
this chicks only fans account like i'm
perfectly fine with that
then maybe you're perfectly fine but if
you're asking us yeah if it's an issue
it's already an interesting answer
no answer is there's an issue with you
know
especially when that money should have
been towards something special for your
birthday
yeah you doesn't even have money to blow
like that no
he's just an idiot yeah so you're
telling me he's financially stupid too
like that with that
guy you live with him yeah i hate him so
much oh my god
oh i bet he uses two in one shampoo
[ __ ] [ __ ]
all right he probably uses dish soap in
the shower
anyways i hate him so much all right
next one
please give me advice all right so over
two years ago i started a job and my
boss came on to me
i was 18 at the time wait what okay
i was 18 at the time and he was 55
married and had more than six kids
whoa who more than six
he's like a total
at first it started out as a daddy kink
he wanted control over me
which was scary and felt uncomfortable
but after a while i just kind of got
used to wait wait
what wait so she's engaging in an affair
with this married man yeah
she said it was and they're yeah they
just went straight to [ __ ] bdsm
wait it was scary and uncomfortable at
first but after a while i just kind of
got used to it you just kind of got
wait what are you doing she was in too
deep
you don't just kind of get used to it
and go with it she just killed
so many details i know you don't just
jump straight to the daddy kink
whoa girl whoa i need like a lot more
[ __ ] details about how you go from
remember
she's 18. she is 18. this is like
something she's into
she's a baby yeah this is [ __ ] up but
go ahead
she also has a lot of a lot of i feel
like we should put a trigger warning up
right now because this [ __ ]
sounds already [ __ ] up yeah if you're
if you're the girl watching right now i
bet you five bucks
i'll bet you guys all five bucks right
now he he has told her you're so mature
for your age
oh yeah i bet you five bucks that's the
most [ __ ] classic grooming line ever
yeah i've heard that one a thousand
times his wife almost caught us once and
definitely started to not like me yeah
no [ __ ]
god jesus color be surprised girlfriend
the way she's even typing this out i'm
like
what um oh man
wait she needs help right yeah i feel
like it yeah
i don't know because she's like i need
help and i'm like yeah you need
help yeah you need help i ended the job
but not our relationship it's just about
two years later and i'm really now
dependent on him
she's tweeting what way financially
daddy king moved to the side and it was
more like a committed relationship
except obviously he was still married
and lying to his family
but not it's definitely more of a loving
relationship he makes it very clear he
doesn't know what he wants from his life
and i'm pretty positive he's not going
to change anytime soon
but is it wrong that i don't want to
break it off yes
i don't have any expectations for him
but he helps distract me from what's
going on at home
i do love him help also i want to let
you know that during my life guarding
job i would sneak an earbud in my left
ear and listen to big mood all day and
kind of zoned out and kind of not watch
the children in the pool
hence why i have an anonymous instagram
account so kids are dying
thank you for being our fan thank you
for being um loyal but
we love our we we love the listeners and
viewers of this show
but i'm very upset with you have you
guys been washing your hair during this
pandemic
barely once a month i know i've barely
been washing my hair
but when i do wash my hair i love to use
function of beauty
honestly i've this this last bottle that
i bought has lasted
no joke once a week but i do
love function of beauty and i i have
bleached hair that is very fragile so
when i went
onto the function of beauty website took
my little quiz i said look
i got very fine hair and it's bleached
and it sucks so help me and then they
sent me a bottle
of the purple shampoo because that
really helps for bleached hair to keep
it from turning too yellow
because you know i already look like
white trash i don't need
that much more white trash in my style
so you know the purple shampoo helps me
function of beauty is a world leader in
customizable beauty offering 100 custom
solutions just for you
first you take a quick but thorough quiz
tell them about your hair goals
next the team determines the right blend
of ingredients and bottles your custom
formula
to order then they deliver your
personalized formula right to your door
in a cute customized bottle they even
print your name on it
they use only clean ingredients and all
of their formulas are vegan and cruelty
free they never use sulfates parabens or
anything other harmful stuff on your
skin
function of beauty now offers a new skin
care line have you guys tried the body
wash in the lotion
the lotion i also have the body wash
i've been using all pretty much all
functional beauty products now
um i've been excited to try the body
wash but i'm currently using a different
one
so i'm like hurry up and finish so i can
use this girl just pop that one in front
of the line it's worth it
um it's the same quality and
customization you expect
you expect and now for your skincare
routine so yeah they'll say like is your
skin
super dry or is it super oily so you can
figure out what you need
you could also customize the scents and
the colors yes because like the one
my body lotion that i have is like
eucalyptus so when i put it on my body
it has like that tingly like minty
tingle so what are you waiting for go to
functionalbeauty.com
big mood to take your quiz and save 20
off your first hair care order go to
functionalbeauty.com
big mood to let them know you heard
about it from our show and get 20
off of your hair care order that's
functionalbeauty.com
big mood i'm so glad i'm not the only
one that hasn't been washing my hair
yep i am disgusting yeah huge shout out
to our sponsor today
meesan i don't know about you but i've
been cooking a lot more at home lately
something i learned pretty quickly is
that using a good knife makes
all the difference it really does have
you ever cut a tomato
like a kind of over ripe tomato
with an unsharp knife it is terrible
but when you have a sharp knife it
creates
beautiful gorgeous if you will tomato
slices
and dices miso makes it really easy for
you they've designed their chef's
knife to replace an entire set of knives
that means you can
you can cut bread with it you could cut
potatoes you could cut you could cut
tomatoes
you could get broccoli eat some broccoli
this is my christopher walken impression
i'm sorry um a dull knife is a dangerous
knife
and it makes cooking more difficult but
with the mise and chef's knife i can
slice through anything like like it's
nothing like it's butter
it makes cooking so much easier and so
much more fun because
i don't know if you've done a lot of
like prep work for different meals but
it's annoying if you're trying to chop
and slice and dice all the stuff and
it's a
and you don't have a good knife so do
yourself a favor please
uh the miesen's chef knife is legit and
verified it has over 5000 five-star
reviews from
real actual pro chefs so don't take my
word for it there's
actual professional chefs out there who
can vouch
and it also has a cult following among
home and chefs and foodies
step up your cooking game now and head
over to mizin.com
big mood for 20 off your first order
that's misen
dot com slash big mood for twenty
percent off your first order
meizen.com big mood
mizin.com slash big mood
thank you for being our fan thank you
for being um loyal but
we love our we we love the listeners of
this and viewers of this show
but i'm very upset with you you can't do
this yeah
you're not right it's not you're not
completely
you're not right in the head right now
you have to seek some help some
professional help
because she did get groomed this is very
yeah but it's very obvious that she has
a lot of issues going on at home
to even like the fact that the scene to
engage in this kind of like daddy
and also she even said it at towards the
end how like he's distracting her from
what's happening
yeah her own her own space so she really
needs to seek
professional help to deal with what's
going on at home
she needs to break up break this off
with this man first get rid of him
yeah that that should be first well the
reason why i did i didn't
list it first is because i think she
really needs she's gonna be her
psychological
help to even break that off yeah like i
don't think she needs
she needs therapy right yeah yeah so
that's why i'm like
yeah this girl like i this man is
using you as a distraction from his life
also and for sex
this is gross in a creepy way a
five-year-old man like if he was gonna
chew why can't he cheat with like i
don't know 35 year old or a 45 year old
like an 18 year old like there's
something wrong in his head you're not
even old enough for him to take out to
the bars
no buy you a drink she sounds like she
has some serious he probably has
kids that ate like close to that age
probably
yeah yeah this isn't love no because
i want you to understand one thing never
not even for a single moment in this
whole entire relationship that you have
with him
have you ever been the only woman ever
have you ever been the only woman that's
on his mind
he has a wife and a family but the the
deeper level than that though is that
she doesn't care
she doesn't care about that which means
like she has some
serious issues that she needs to work
out about herself
the fact that she's even okay with the
situation
like that's not that's not something
like like it's not like me or you
right in this situation you know this is
a girl that is completely so far
gone out there that she needs genuine
help yeah i don't want to victim blame
because i i do see the grooming
side of it um but i am very upset with
her and i want her to
to do better i just want her to watch
the kids when she's lifeguarding you
know okay
like that too yeah die dude come on you
have one job
keep them alive i yeah
i mean there really isn't so much more
to say other than
she does need some sort of therapy i
don't even know where to begin with that
but then where are she gonna get therapy
at this age she can't afford it
you know yeah that's a lot of self-hate
in her
like she's just she probably is feeling
like well you know what i'm already a
shitty person so might as well do shitty
things
[ __ ] it and i think that's that's
that's what i mean by like there's some
really deep seated issues there and for
sure she has some daddy issues or
or maybe it's mommy issues manifesting
in this
way and there's some serious
serious [ __ ] there that she needs to
like there's like gunk in there she
needs to clean out because
her mind is polluted right now to the
point where she thinks that the
situation she's in is like
it's cool she sees it as love you know
like there's
that's some of the most twisted form of
love
like you it feels like love maybe or it
gives you the same chemical release as
what you think love is but literally
factually
i don't think it is right like i don't i
can't
envision how that is healthy
in any way or that it's actually true
love in any way it's like two people
using each other
yeah but i i feel like less that she's
at fault for the situation just because
she is so young
she's more impressionable she says that
now she's fully dependent on him and i
wonder
in what way like i know for you know
like does he take care of her the
beginning
the king thing the daddy wasn't that
like it was a daddy king
moved on to a she said now a it's moved
aside and now it's committed to
relationship
and it was her boss it was her boss so
maybe he's just like
he paid so she didn't have to work
anymore she's paying for her job
but now she's a lifeguard oh shitty one
um
um but she said that she's dependent on
him now like how is he
taking care of her he has to be somehow
right there's other ways i don't know
there's other things
in trying to do maybe what feels
easy even though it's like super
unhealthy is just really gonna
like dig her into a deeper and deeper
hole
so like yeah i mean this person is
probably not gonna be one that wants to
help themselves
right so she says um
he says that he doesn't know what he
wants and i'm pretty positive he's not
going to change oh he's not leaving his
wife he's not
he's never ever she says i don't have
any expectations for him that's the line
that sticks out i don't have any exactly
he sticks out to me a lot too
i don't have any expectations for him
but he helps distract me from what's
going on at home
so it's kind of like being apathetic
about having a drug problem you're like
i i it is what it is like i know it's
unhealthy and it is what it is so it's
like yeah
you've got to figure out a way to love
yourself i think that
whatever happened to you is definitely
holding you back
yeah and there's love it's it's
dependent like you said it yourself
you're dependent on him
yeah and i this this is beyond
any like relationship this is like some
some some mental health
like you need some therapy to help you
do this
yeah i mean period on that one girl yep
so pack your bags we're not going we're
not going to the streets
no we're not going to therapy yeah pack
your bags
there's got to be some sort of like some
sort of resources of
just somewhere to even start i mean i
know definitely there's there's like
apps that even sponsor us that you can
literally go to
and it's affordable and you can you can
make you can take a first step you know
there's always
there's probably like free stuff
sponsored by the city or whatever
there's probably
like free mental health stuff that that
i mean i would start with the therapist
for sure
yeah i just want to email this guy's
wife so bad oh i know i'm like girl give
us a detail
he might not leave her but we can make
her leave him
she doesn't deserve to be married to a
man that's just [ __ ]
dating an 18 year old i just want to be
the neighbor next door when this all
blows up
[Laughter]
stuck to everything oh my goodness
jesus christ well yeah that's um yeah no
get therapy also [ __ ] watch the kids
please
no that's that like the the lifeguard
part
was also another in like inclination to
me that
she is very self-hating and that she's
just like
[ __ ] it i'm a shitty ass person anyway
[ __ ] it like that that's that's the kind
of action and the fact that
she even told us about that that is she
knows problems do you admit that
yeah she knows it was under anonymous
account like fully anonymous but she
knows
yeah all right oh god these are
god these are sending me [ __ ] uh the
last one i can't even handle anymore
just you take a lot last one go
okay i did have one um it's it's a it's
from a guy's perspective i think all
these were from a girl's perspective
um this guy
is telling me okay so i'll just read it
this is kind of long
and maybe i'll have to skip some parts
or whatever because it's it's it's
definitely a long story but anyway here
we go
as a guy who listens to the podcast i
also went through a toxic and mentally
abusive relationship for five years
i don't know how old they were at this
point but the first three years were
magical i loved her she loved me
everything was beautiful
till we began to grow apart she was
three years younger than me at an early
age
i got most of my partying out of my
system and i mainly enjoyed the dive bar
scene
and she was just getting into raving
when i got out
so okay i guess he was a raver and then
he like grew out of it and just liked
five bars and now she's like starting to
race so they must be like 18 like young
yeah
super young yeah she found new friends
started thinking i was always
being condescending towards her because
i had already lived through that phase
but i was always supportive and just
wanted her to experience it all
but she would always say i didn't like
her acting that way when in reality i
love see her opening
and enjoying herself i don't really get
the point of that
um i think he's probably trying to
justify the
typical arguments that she's thrown at
him
like you like perspective yeah like
maybe he made her feel like or maybe she
was insecure like oh she's doing all
this raving stuff and he's like oh yeah
back in my day you know like i already
did all that
like and she maybe it made her feel
insecure but yeah i didn't really
understand the point of that
bit of information but anyways um it was
i loved seeing her open up and enjoying
herself it was the reason i fell in love
with her anytime she experienced
something new the way her her eyes would
light up
i wanted to give her the world so he
loves her
i believe him she started experimenting
with drugs
and here we go i had just i had just
gone sober from hard drugs before we
started dating so i guess he was in the
rave scene he was on drugs he cleaned
himself up and now he just goes to dive
bar so that's where we're at
he had a uh i had a this is from his
perspective i had a cocaine and ecstasy
addiction that i kicked when i met her
and she knew i was traumatized from it
but she wanted to start
sharing her experience with me
so obviously we know that this is a
[ __ ] problem because if you're a drug
addict
and you quit and you're gonna start
involving yourself with someone who is
an active drug user
it's not gonna be an absolute terrible
situation
um so i went down that path so i could
see her eyes light up again
oh no so that oh so he relapsed
yes so i feel like i have an issue with
that sentence like
he loves her so much right but what part
of that like
like knowing how the bad the drugs are
makes you
want to see her happy he started doing
it with her so they can enjoy it
together
or like it makes her happy so he likes
to see your eyes light up he likes to
see her i guess maybe when she's high
maybe she's happy and he just wants to
do anything to make her happy but i
wonder how much of that comes from his
own like
willingness and like quiet wanting to
like start using again sure you know
but anyways um we started doing a lot of
cocaine i started doing a lot more
she would say i'm emotionally unstable
because of it well yeah no [ __ ]
we would fight then she'd want me to get
us more her friends would always want me
to bring more and more because i had all
the connections and drugs
i started losing her we started growing
apart
i felt like i changed her into this
shadow of a person
so i kind of i do think so because he's
seeing like
she's like when they met everything was
good and now they're getting deeper and
deeper
into drugs and like he's seeing her
become the shell of a drug addict
like so he's at least able to realize he
had some personal responsibility
yeah um i wanted us to quit and i wanted
us to be better
uh then my grandmother passed away on my
death on her death bed she told me to
marry this girl and that she loves me
very dearly
i don't know if grandma knew all the
yeah situation
but um yeah for the last two years of
our relationship or what was left of it
we forced ourselves to spend time with
each other
she constantly tell me i wasn't the same
since my grandmother passed
um i did everything i could to be the
guy she fell in love with bought her
gifts took her to places
planned cute dates by the river packed a
picnic basket full of sushi and wine to
the beach
yes because we love to see it yeah we
like it
he's trying at this point um so kudos
for that part
everything led to a fight somehow and it
was always my fault i truly loved her
but i knew
she was only with me out of pity she
constantly tell me she doesn't see a
future with us but always be the one
coming back whenever i would try to move
on from her
hmm
because she's a drug addict probably and
it's familiar
at this point maybe she's one of those
like okay i don't want to be with you
but you were not allowed to be with
anyone else that's talks that's what it
sounds like yeah
the last straw was a win on valentine's
day i bought her a pair of the dr
martins that she was in love with i
arranged a flower bouquet
myself of all her favorite flowers a
basket full of her favorite candies
i know he's so thoughtful he's like he
has like all the right
like intentions right i brought them to
her and surprise her before work she
looked sad
when she accepted them and said she
didn't get him anything
for valentine's day so he said i didn't
need anything from her i just wanted to
see her face light up again but it
didn't that's when i knew
i had to stop the cycle we didn't talk
for a day or two she
she called asking why it was distant i
told her you know i know you don't love
me anymore and it's okay
so they started crying together she said
um you've been amazing i love you but i
don't know what i want anymore
so i completely understood her and told
her i wanted her to be happy
and um then she started so basically
they parted ways for a month
um they weren't they went no contact on
social media and everything
then she started getting drunk calls he
started getting drunk calls from her
blaming him for how [ __ ] up she was
and how but then also how she loved him
she wanted him to come
see her and bring her more coke so the
drug addiction was
getting [ __ ] crazy yeah um so anyways
this whole vicious toxic cycle
goes on and on uh she went crazy telling
everyone on social media how
she saved me from killing myself and
that she was scared of what i would do
that i'd break into her house and harm
her so basically she's just like
starting to like poke manic like yeah
that's what it sounds like
needs the connection and that's probably
her only connection which is
him and that's why she's stringing
there's like these manipulative ways of
like this
public embarrassment and all this [ __ ]
to like get him to do
what she wants him to do which is get
her drugs um but anyway
people would send me screenshots of how
she was telling people i was psychotic
everyone replied
that's not the guy we know still to this
day she still tries to contact me and
stay in touch when she's in trouble or a
bad situation always tell her
i can only be your friend because i
always care for her but she won't get
that side of me anymore
uh am i wrong for answering her calls
and still enabling her behavior
i think you already know the answer the
fact that he phrased it that way
yeah whenever i need someone she always
has an excuse and ends up blocking me
am i not allowing myself to heal
absolutely
am i an idiot who's insane no no
it sounds like he tried yeah i think so
please let me know what you think guilty
from the whole drug thing because
he had already moved away and she was
like wait but i've never tried it let's
try it together and he was like okay
fine
so i think it's that guilt the fact that
now she led her into this
like cocaine abyss but i honestly
believe that
she was gonna do it anyway yeah she
started without him though
she had her own group she was getting
into the rave scene or whatever like
already out yeah yeah but the sad part
is that
he felt like enabling her
and he like he wanted to be cool for her
maybe yeah like
that he loved her so he got back into
drugs for her like that's just really
[ __ ] sad
all this is just bad she's terrible for
him she's back into his drug addiction
and like now treating him like this even
after her breakup she's
extremely toxic he's also i mean he said
it himself he's enabling her though
by continuously keeping her in his life
and i know what he's keeping her in his
life because he still loves her it
sounds like
i think he does really love her because
guys who [ __ ] put little picnic
baskets together
and [ __ ] make a bouquet themselves
like instead of just buying a bouquet
they make one themselves like
i think he really [ __ ] loves her but
duh so sad
she doesn't deserve that love she no no
she has a lot of she's not
she can't even she's not available yeah
she can't reciprocate at all
yeah this this is a sad scenario
my heart really does go up for this guy
yeah uh
the first three years sure were
incredible but i'm assuming it's because
they were also very young
and i'm assuming that they're going into
their either they're heading into
mid-20s now probably
sounds like it probably yeah and those
are very a lot of things
change during those years very rapidly
too very rapidly yeah
and she for
unfortunately she's changing for the
worse and he seems like he's making up
an effort to be better yeah he pulled
himself out of drugs yeah he tried to
fix the relationship
even he was the one who sat down and
told himself like
you know i knew i know this isn't going
to work out and told her i know you
don't love me
like i think he you're very self-aware
you know what's going on and you're
asking us these questions when you
already know the answers
you know you just want to hear it from
us right and the people in the comments
it's very obvious that yes you should
cut her off yes you are enabling her by
answering the phone
yes we understand why you're doing it
because you have that history with her
but it's not gonna help her and it's not
gonna help you right and the time that
you're wasting
on her on this toxicity you're
stealing from the time that you could be
using to
better yourself or even find someone who
deserves all that love in the picnic
baskets that you
make you know so cute like you know
that's adorable
you know how many girls would love to
get that little picnic basket with a
sushi in it
right but now this story like i
responded to this
story because when i was 18 i fell in
love with a guy who was a drug addict
and he actually got me into drugs it
wasn't like i was seeking it out or
anything but like
i think you know a couple years into
that like i
i got really bad into like so i hit rock
bottom really fast like i think it was
just in my dna
like addiction is there like and clearly
looking at my mom
in her situation like i have the the um
propensity to be a terrible [ __ ]
addict so
after just two years of doing coke like
it was very unhealthy i feel like i can
almost
picture like how their nights were manic
on coke like just
unhealthy um and so it really struck a
chord with me
but the thing is like i had to leave
that and i had to just
go completely no contact with that guy
in order to get off the drugs
and so yeah if he's answering her call
or if he's like still getting it for her
or anything like he has to absolutely
stop that
right now this isn't love look at the
way she's talking about you online dude
love doesn't tell people that you're
psychotic and like
well he probably sees through the drug
part of it right like he's he probably
knows like she's only saying this
stuff because she knows like she doesn't
feeding for
drugs yeah yeah for sure
but to love her you have her love the
way that you think that is
yeah just by still responding to her and
stuff but what are you getting back
i really think it's the guilt that he
feels
i think that's the reason why it's the
guilt and the love that he still has for
her
so those are the two main reasons i see
as to why he's still responding to her
and so he's really just
it's self-serving for him and it's not
helping him or her
yeah and so it's just really he's like
letting himself be a punching bag kind
of for
this extended period of time in order to
feel like it's going to make it
okay someday but nothing like until she
gets clean on her own
nothing none of your interactions are
going to be healthy none of them are
going to be helpful
for you or her i mean
it seems pretty terrible it's so savvy i
broke my heart because
like when guys describe like how they go
out of their way to do cute [ __ ] for
girls and like
not enough guys do that i know they
don't get credit when they do
i want picnics but the one that doesn't
have cocaine in it
how much sugar in my tea not cocaine
yeah i wouldn't have been eating any of
that and i would have just been high as
[ __ ]
i'd not even be hungry yeah she's like i
can't eat any of this honey
it's so like not thoughtful of you you
know
dang i know this one's happening oh
honey it breaks my heart
how like he he really truly loved her
though
yeah you can tell just by the way he
writes about her yeah
he loves her it's really sad like drugs
are obviously a huge
problem in the whole entire world in our
country especially but
everywhere i mean people have issues
with drugs but being in
you can't mix a relationship with drugs
it doesn't work i mean i can't imagine
any maybe one percent of them you can
you can point to
a relationship that has drugs in it that
actually they both got clean and it
worked out and they're still together
like
who you are when you're on drugs and you
fall in love when you're on drugs and
all this stuff like
you're creating these memories and stuff
of a person who's not even really you
yeah it's like a fantasy yeah and then
so when when those addictions fall apart
then a lot of
what your relationship stood on also
falls apart true
so there really just is no where for
this relationship to go
and i think he knew that which is why he
left but if anybody else is in
you know that type of situation where
it's intertwined with any type of drug
addiction it's
it's got i'm just gonna say you have
zero hope and you just
get out of it i will say however i'm
very proud of him for leaving for
understanding and knowing like you know
that
she doesn't love me and i need to get
out you are lingering but i'm proud of
you for pulling out completely
no i'm sorry not completely i am proud
of you for pulling out most of the way
most of the way yeah and getting out and
ending the relationship when you needed
to
true yeah pack your bags
he already hasn't packed he just needs
to take them out the door yeah
close the door we're going through tsa
they will check for drugs there are drug
dogs
back to the streets with you back to the
street the nice suburb streets like it's
you're a sweetheart you get the suburbs
yeah he's not made for the streets he's
made for a good girl he'll get there
eventually
yeah yeah stop me on that
it's not gonna help i love you we love
you yeah so what about these uh
so we got a ton of submissions um and we
we definitely want to try to do this
type of episode again i like it what
kind of stuff would you ladies
like to hear though like what kind of
problems
dude these were pretty like i was on an
emotional rollercoaster today
is that that only fans one oh yeah i'm
still angry that one got under my skin
yeah there's hate back there's so many
to like we were reading through a lot of
them too
and like there's just so many shitty
boyfriends out there and i'm like girl
what the [ __ ] are you even asking like
you even gotta ask but i forget
because when i was younger too i put up
with so much
[ __ ] yeah like it's just
i don't even know how to how to like get
a girl
to the right mentality to like stop
right
well all kinds of experiences are
important to get there
yeah i guess because if i hadn't gone if
i hadn't gone through all the [ __ ] that
like upset me so much and like being
treated like [ __ ] and cheated on and all
that stuff and like still putting up
with it and still trying and like
then you realize like you don't need
to try like when they're that shitty
like nothing you can do is gonna change
them
right right yeah zero effort zero
investment
they're not gonna just all of a sudden
one day be prince charming you're
wasting your time
and like i always say if they really
wanted to they
they would they would you'll see some
sort of progress
i'm not a churchy person but i was in
love and i wanted to you know i want to
make you happy and if you want to go to
church i'll go with you
because if i really wanted to make you
happy i would you know
any little thing like that yeah i need a
little thing so
when it comes like the first person who
wanted attention
if he wanted to he would the second one
for it's sushi if he wanted to he would
right
but he wants to pay for only fans [ __ ]
so that's what he did
yeah so keep that in mind we love these
questions
thanks for sending them in uh we're
gonna i feel like we should keep doing
this
yeah i think it was fun tell us what you
guys think yeah the title should be
should we go back to the streets
yeah should we should we pack our bags
you know uh thank you guys for watching
this episode of big mood thank you guys
for your submissions make sure you guys
follow our instagram because we do
post on there and reach out when we need
uh you to ask us some questions and do
some submissions so we can answer them
on our show um make sure you give us a
thumbs up on our video
five stars whatever it is that people
are rating people five potatoes i don't
know
leave a comment leave a comment interact
tell us
what you would have got what you guys
would have done in these situations
and also tell me how pissed you are
about this only fans guy because
i want to be in those comments too just
so serious message her back
i just i feel like we should go beat his
ass that's what i'm saying
like i just want a girl gang to go yeah
yeah you know like i
like i'm gonna message her but thanks
for watching you guys we'll see you guys
next week take care we love you
be good take care of yourselves be nice
to each other bye